hello there i i can't do that on every
ob one video okay so this was a day of
reveals and surprises man we got a new
valkyrie profile game coming out we have
a ninja turtles retro game collection
coming out a thing we got that i did not
expect not that i expected the other two
was a trailer for the obi-wan kenobi
series because this is it this is the
story that star wars fans myself
included have wanted to see since
birth now we have a trailer for this
story this series that i
really hope they don't screw up as far
as trailers go it starts out amazing and
just
it's a really good trailer for the
moment you have obi-wan kenobi talking
like the fighting's over
we lost i mean technically speaking you
didn't you won you just didn't know you
didn't want to win you fought for
palpatine's government palpatine's
government won i get it you were
deceived by a lie we all were and that
right there i love that line i love a
lot of lines in this trailer to be
honest but i love that line because that
really does reflect what i've wanted to
see in an obi-wan series this person
who's just like
we lost i lost my world not just my
world i trained the guy who became one
of the guys who've destroyed the world
not saying planet obscene world world
can encompass an entire galaxy when the
galaxy's all interconnected as it is in
star wars and the moment that duel of
the fates hits the goron and you see
lucasfilm and blows away like sand i was
like huh okay great music choice great
music choices in this trailer duel of
the face really kicks it on uh that's
getting a lot of the conversation but
battle of the heroes from revenge of the
sith that's also in there duel the fate
starts it out the entire the crux of the
trailer the the meat and bones of the
music is battle of the heroes it looks
like we're getting more space adventure
than i ever asked for for an obi-wan
series that takes place in this time
frame more inquisitors laser space
battles we know i mean obi-wan and vader
are probably going to clash in this
movie so in the meantime we have
inquisitors and i kind of have a
love-hate relationship with inquisitors
at first i totally get it cause like no
one in star wars rebels can take on
darth vader it's just impossible but we
need lightsaber fights all right
inquisitors grand inquisitor great and
rebels i we see him in here and he's
pretty menacing he has this great line
in here where he's talking about how a
jedi's code is like an itch they can't
help it so you know just torture people
and we'll bring the jedi out of hiding
and then we just kill him that's some
pretty sinister [ __ ] i love that but i
got to the point where every time i
would see an inquisitor do something i
felt like it was screen time i could
have seen vader do something vader's out
there being like big boss just has this
fulton system like okay you want to work
for me great boom you're an inquisitor
now people who aren't metal gear fans
are like the [ __ ] is he talking about
but on the other hand to be fair jedi
fallen order did the inquisitor's
storyline really well i thought that was
very well done but it looks too i mean
this is where we get into you know it
trailers out so now theorizing is part
of the fun of trailers star wars
trailers in particular it's always been
just a hub of theorizing but it looks
like the inquisitors the empire they've
come to tatooine for a reason almost
like they've sensed something and maybe
i'm seeing it through the goggles of
well i played jedi fallen order so i
kind of saw that happening there someone
used the force now the inquisitors have
shown up they're like okay
let's weed them out let's kill them the
only thing is if that be the case if
that's what brings them there if that's
why they are on tatooine i'm not
entirely convinced it was obi-wan i'm
not entirely convinced it wouldn't be
luke let's face it that'd be kind of
interesting wouldn't it like anakin
skywalker when he was racing pause he
was really good at pod racing because he
was at the subconscious level using jedi
reflex as though he didn't know what it
was he didn't know what he was doing
he's had good reflexes i could see
something like that happening with luke
where luke just subconsciously i don't
know he does something bull's-eye says
womp rats with his t-16 maybe he's a
little young to do that but
i was tattooing that plan is not exactly
up to code it's not exactly the safest
place in the galaxy i'm sure kids start
bulls eyeing their womp rats at age
three it'd be interesting to see if the
inquisitors show up because they sense
the force being used and whether or not
that was luke and that would answer that
question the question of why is uncle
owen such a grumpy dick in a new hope i
could see it being a case where he was
like dude we took this kid in because i
was his uncle i felt like it was the
right thing to do then he moved a grain
of sand on the ground with his mind and
now these super evil space wizards are
coming trying to kill him you know what
luke guess what
good news you get to be a farmer forever
well you have hopes and dreams you have
[ __ ] that [ __ ] farmer forever harvest is
when i need you the most knee-deep in
twilight so you can meet trust me this
is the life god willing we all get to
die old grumpy ass men one day guess
you'll get to do that even when you are
a jedi
that's unexpected there's a good trailer
i i just really hope they keep it in the
pocket here i'm seeing a lot of
inquisitors do a lot of inquisitor
things and as much as it does a lot the
opportunity to afford the opportunity to
show jedi being hunted down or at least
the process of it something again we did
see in jedi following order so there is
that i don't want it to be like oh
obi-wan kenobi should have been called
the inquisitors keeping the family
dynamic at the center of owen luke vader
obi-wan obi-wan's family keeping that
family dynamic at the center using the
inquisitors to basically get it churning
but not having the inquisitors hijack
the series that'll be the test right
there that's where balance comes in so
we'll see what happens but i had to do a
video on this because thus far
that obi-wan kenobi trailer that was a
great trailer the biggest question i
have on my mind in this trailer is does
that inquisitor know that that is her
boss's stepbrother all right so the
obi-wan kenobi trailer have you seen it
what did you think about it are you
looking forward to the obi-wan kenobi
series do you have faith in it whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]
you